tenemos aquí cuatro números algunos
tienen un signo negativo otros tienen un
valor absoluto o puntos decimales pero
el chiste es que queremos ordenar estos
cuatro números de izquierda a derecha de
tal forma que los chicos estén a la
izquierda y los más grandes estén a la
derecha y bueno como siempre te
recomiendo que le pongas una pausa y
trates de resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno estoy suponiendo que ya lo
intentaste la forma en la que a mí me
gusta resolverlo es pensar en una recta
numérica y graficar cada uno de estos
valores ahí
y puedes dibujar la recta numérica así
como yo por aquí o puedes no dibujarla y
pensar en esta recta numérica en tu
cabeza y listo
pero bueno empecemos con este número
aquí el valor absoluto de menos 27 así
es que cuál es el valor absoluto de
menos 27 pues eso es simplemente 27
porque menos 27 son 27 saltos a la
izquierda pero si tomamos el valor
absoluto tenemos que tomar esa misma
cantidad de saltos pero siempre a la
derecha entonces si queremos graficar el
valor absoluto de menos 27 lo vamos a
encontrar por aquí ok
aquí está el valor absoluto de menos 27
justo en el 27 bueno ahora vamos con
menos 17
cada una de estas marcas representa a
tres enteros
aquí tenemos menos nueve y aquí se va
hasta menos 18 entonces de menos 9 aquí
saltamos a menos 12 y luego a menos 15
menos 17 debe de estar más o menos por
aquí menos 17 y luego queremos graficar
menos 28 y cada una de estas marcas
representa tres enteros entonces nos
vamos a menos 27 y aquí por aquí está el
menos 28 y finalmente 22.4 ok entonces
nos vamos al 18 y cada una de estas
marcas son tres enteros entonces esta
marca es la del 21 por aquí debe estar
el 22 y si nos vamos un poquitito para
acá está el 22.4 aunque 22.4 más o menos
por aquí entonces si queremos ordenar
estos cuatro números de chico a grande
lo único que tenemos que hacer es fijar
en la recta numérica y ahí ya están
acomodados ok entonces el más chico es
menos 28 menos 28 después tenemos al
menos 17 menos 17 luego está el 22.4
22.4 y finalmente el valor absoluto de
menos 27 valor absoluto de menos 37 y
terminamos